- And it's just like
Ted hello, quit being a cock block.
It's annoying--
- He does that.
He does that, it's a problem.
Stop.
- Oh no, it's Margaret.
Not good.
She is so obsessed with me.
Yeah, it's insane.
Like every time I come to this bar
she's like, "Hey!"
I'm just like, "Hey, can't you see
"I'm just trying to hang
out with my friends?"
- Yeah.
- You know it's guys'
night out, take it easy.
Just go ahead, ignore her, Zach, okay.
She's in love with me.
I feel embarrassed for her,
you know what I'm saying.
I just wanna like save her some face.
I wanna go over there and
be like hey girl, listen,
there are plenty other fish in the sea,
you don't have to go for
this forbidden fruit.
Why don't you try someone else, anyone!
Except me, you know.
- I actually think she's waving at me.
- Don't be ridiculous Zach,
she's in love with me.
I'm the one that's cute.
- Hi.
- [Zach] Hi.
- I'm Margaret.
- I'm Zach nice to meet you.
- Oh boy, here we go.
Classic Margaret, just waltzing over
tryna get to me through my friends.
- [Margaret] Am I bothering
you again, Justin?
- Yeah, Margaret, as a
matter of fact you are
and to be quite frank it's gettin' old.
I'm flattered that you're so
enamored with me but it's
never gonna work out.
- Oh my god, Justin,
please get over yourself.
I'm not interested in you,
I'm never interested in you.
It's always your cute friends.
And you always cock block
me every single time.
You know what, I'm gonna
give my number to Zach.
Call me anytime, just
leave Justin at home.
- Yeah.
Man it's a shame that
girl's obsessed with you,
that could have been my dream girl.
(upbeat electronic music)